las
quand
[Musique]
m
hop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
me dire
mary au premier rang bien venir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas quelqu'un qui veut le faire
il ya quelqu'un qui veut le faire est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un dans la salle qui
peut le faire ouais ouais ça va givet
aucun ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
quelqu'un là qui veulent faire avancer
leurs prédicateurs chrétiens il est what
to do sacrifice armes et son sourire
carnassier thierry ardisson l'a testé
pour vous un pas les panthères de
froufrous les tigres ian bruce
[Musique]
c'est un mal il s'appelle tango tango
tango
il me rappelle un patron de chaîne que
j'ai bien connue dans le temps celui là
c'est un mâle également il s'appelle
cian way sympa trois voiliers ben c'est
une femelle ça non c'est un mal avant
oui oui certaines souli assez subi souli
voilà la femelle alors voilà elle
s'appelle hors jo bonjour en zoo j'ai
bien connu des tigresses
oui là c'est arras c'est un mâle
également par as quel âge il a quatre
ans bon allez faire dresser un peu non
allez en avoir un
grâce aux eaux oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh c'est assez dingue
oh oh oh oh oh ok maintenant à faire
marcher un peu leur zone allez on y va
alors saut allez hop et alleo et en os
[Musique]
allez bagot banon d'accord maintenant
et oh là là bas grâce race
ap
non
la bien yalla yalla tient commirent tago
commirent d'arras à z os
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah ouais les zèbres
je vais faire un je vais faire un don
stage de zèbres non moi je me suis
demandé pourquoi ce que thierry ardisson
a choisi les tigres parce que tout de
même quand on voit rien que la taille du
coup signer un nom mais c'est simplement
pour débarrasser la télévision de
thierry ardisson beaucoup de gens s'y
sont essayés ils n'ont pas encore réussi
donc je me suis dit qu'il fallait les
aider à penser aux tigres
dix minutes avec ardisson les pauvres ça
je crois que le pire c'est pour les tire
effectivement dix minutes avec un 10 ans
surtout qu'à quelqu'un qui leur avait
expliqué que c'est le nom d'une marque
de biscuits ardisson donc effectivement
il était assez affamés manger un
craquant à la craquante
il a suivi les conseils de france 2 il a
osé affronter les tigres
il mérite des applaudissements thierry
sort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
le lean hardy tube abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu